welcome back to new rockstars as the mcu
continues to add projects to its
pipeline we cannot help but get excited
about some of the new heroes we could be
seeing soon in the mcu and what's that
on the horizon could it be the most
powerful hero of all the strongest hero
in marvel history my dream the frog man
probably not but you know a man can
dream i shouldn't leap to conclusions
this is rogue theory the show where we
pitch the wildest theories for the nerdy
titles that we love my name is mt and
growing the road with me today is the
number one supporter for bringing the
mcluhan's to the mcu it's jessica
clements what's going on girl bring them
in i want to know more about the 10
rings i want 10 rings not ariana grande
seven rings not to could be confused
with ariana grande seven rings i want
the ten we need a little three more
rings we need three more yeah plus three
please and someone who is just waiting
for squirrel girl to show up already
it's whitney van laningham what's going
on with me
squirrel girl and uh i would just like
to add that the lovely and talented
angelica trey just tweeted her own
audition tape for squirrel girl and i
would like to endorse trey for the
official squirrel girl she's my casting
that's who i've cast that's who i've
cast yes that would be amazing like you
know what if kevin feige is watching uh
hit up and hey kevin hit up angelica
she's cool she's cool she's cool and
she's just cool in general so just pick
her up general nice lady nice lady and
finally the man who was ready for mojo
to take over the mcu broadcast it's tom
michaelson what's going on tom how's it
fam yeah i'm just a spider chair away
from marty watching all the tv in the
world like mojo so i am so ready for a
mojo to be uh be here next one kevin
feig if you're watching which i know you
do angelica can be a squirrel girl and
i'll be mojo just call me up i'll drop
what i'm doing i'll be ready to i forgot
that mojo hasn't been
i keep thinking and loki for some reason
they've talked about it but mojo hasn't
shown up yet right yeah yeah but like
given like the weird direction the mcu
is going i feel like we're gonna get a
mojo very soon especially after wanda
vision like mojo definitely watched the
wine division with us like that's oh
yeah he didn't miss it yeah for sure but
as i teased at the top marvel is
continuing to add new projects to its
pipeline and while there is still no
nudes on frogman what the heck like come
on i need my frog man in my life we did
get an exciting news item on a new
character this week which leads us to
our first topic today is the mcu about
to go super nova because as deadline
reported this week that marvel studios
is currently developing a project based
around the character nova who everyone
has been waiting for for years ever
since guardians of the galaxy one came
out in 2014 headed up by moonlight
writer sabir pirzada it is being
reported that this nova project will
likely be a limited series versus d plus
so how would you guys like to see nova
introduced in the mcu and with the
off-screen destruction of xandar that
occurred in infinity war what is
possibly even left of the nova corps
what do you guys think okay well i'll
tell you one thing right now about how i
want him to be introduced
okay
i want everyone to say hello to dick
ryder ladies and gentlemen
i say that all the time i really want
them to make that joke i want it to be
either peter quill it's gonna be
hilarious can i maybe picture rule
that if anyone calls him by his
christian name this episode they get a
minus point i don't want to hear richard
i only want to hear the name dick ryder
come out of your mouth
nova's fine
but no
that man is a is a sweet sweet dick
writer you're about to say batman is a
stick but you meant that as a compliment
i heard you were about to say i heard it
i did it it meant that it was like a
really big compliment
but no how would you guys like to see
actual richard river nova minus point
minus one point see i told you i told
you
no but how would you guys like to see
nobody introducing the mcu i think go
forward it would be interesting to see
well i know that they talked about in
the news how dick ryder was supposed to
be in infinity war so it i think
i think they they cut that out because
there'd be too many people in that
freaking movie which is true so i do
think we do need to go back to the fact
that thanos did destroy that planet that
was mentioned in infinity war and see
that as the intro to the um
the mini limited series i think we need
to he needs to just be introduced in his
own series because the world mind is
such a big thing and so cool that they
should discuss like just do like if it's
an hour long episode 30 minutes of like
set up of like how important these
people are the different levels to the
nova corps there are and then get into
like oh here comes saying i was
destroying everything and here's the one
last man on the planet and
to side to what whitney said i think
that joke of dick writer will be made a
ton of times when he somehow meets the
guardians of the galaxy when guardians
of the galaxy
when he meets up with the guardians of
the galaxy he's going to be like i used
to go by richard ryder and then rock is
gonna be like dick writer like
immediately what's gonna happen is that
uh you know he's gonna show up you like
guardians did you get my message he's
like you mean your dick message yeah we
got it
and they'll do a call back to that joke
from from zandaria
no i 100 agree like going to that
destruction of xandar that we did not
see an infinity war which is a huge
bummer but like i understand for the
sake of time why they didn't put that in
there but like we we have to see that in
a nova series
there is no stone on zandar correct
there is nothing there thanos
the power stone was on xander and that
that's what i'm an idiot yeah i was like
ago that i was like what was that why
was he destroying that planet again the
power stopped after guardians yeah the
the nova corps got the possession of the
stone yeah yeah thank you thank you i
totally i totally agree with jess though
i think this show has to open like the
opening we're in the middle of the war
thanos is like decimating xander but the
one thing i would like to really see
is um glenn close as nova prime going
one on one against that maybe we could
pan up from rubble and see her you know
going toe-to-toe almost kind of like how
captain marvel was against thanos and
and then her then being defeated
um and then i also want to see a cameo
from john c reilly
as uh roman day who was also uh you know
no no nova prime maybe he could i don't
know maybe he i don't know if i don't
know if the power is gonna transfer or
what but you know that that could be a
way to
to bring in um
uh peen writer i mean dick ryder uh into
the into the mcu
um peenwriter is his cousin the other
thing i'm really hoping they do is
because the note the nova core is like
marvel's answer to the green lantern
core and you know the green lanterns you
know like
they come to earth and then they give
hal jordan the ring and then now there's
a bunch of other earthling lanterns i
think it'd be cool if maybe they
switched it up and made uh made this
richard ryder like uh
made him from zandar like maybe he's a
teen on xander because we have humanoid
type aliens that live there like glenn
close is no prime so that could be one
way they switch it up and make it
different and maybe he could like last
on a krypton style be the only survivor
or something like that and then he could
be he could be nova that way and then
later in the show they could say other
people survived and then have the nova
core but yeah i'm really hoping we start
with the battle on zandar and bring josh
brolin back have him beat thanos in that
moment kick an ass and then have glenn
close come back have her have a dope
action scene and then yeah have john c
reilly come back
and have it uh have it introduce
everybody that way i really do like this
idea of us i like seeing this huge
battle occur in that we were supposed to
be in see an infinity war but also i
really want to see like just zandar
before it gets destroyed like the light
yeah
we only got like a little scene of that
in guardians yeah and like at the end of
guardians one we see john c reilly's
character have this family with the um i
believe they're called the chimelians
the the pink um skinned no no they're
just pink skin cree but like xandar is
just this huge planet of like so many
different races that was just wiped out
by thanos so like i just want to see
what zandarian culture looked like
before it was destroyed and like this
series would be the perfect answer for
that i really did like tom's idea of
having richard ryder just be originally
from xander because there are
ah sorry dick ryder my bad um dick ryder
being originally from xandar because
there are humanoid um people on xandar
but it would be really cool if like his
mom was human and his dad was
like vice versa just for like him to be
like half and half i think it'd be fun
for a limited series they're going i
agree with um it's like with a limited
series they're gonna have to we know
it's sad to see a family die but
seeing it in like two to three episodes
is different than seeing it just
immediate you'd like oh i don't have
that much attachment but seeing like
having the attachment to zandar would
actually make you feel horrible about
what just happened but i think so they
have to really
sharpen that tone in the script and then
they also have to make it like so
aggressive how important the world mind
is and how it chose richard reiter so i
think it's like if it's a limited series
it has to be oh damn it get it right
[Laughter]
you're not supposed to say the richer
words oh sorry you said the magic word
oh guys but
sorry
people need to know how important the
world mind is for choosing dick ryder uh
such an insult but a compliment at the
same time why is the world by choosing a
dick rider for oh
i think and that's a thing that they
could change from the comics is like
maybe there was more than dick left you
know maybe there was another person
there and the world mind was like i'm
going to choose you and it's like why
choose me that sounds like the uh plot
of why the last man there's there's
there should be more than dick like
oh that's a spoiler for those that
didn't read the comics sorry bleep it
just keep it in but bleep it out these
are all great ideas but whitney what do
you got woody okay so i'm gonna uh go a
little rogue in my direction okay this
is rogue theory you gotta that's the job
so i think that one of two things
might happen
if they decide to introduce dick writer
to us as a teenager
it would be really cool
if
because of a really big plot in his like
comic story line right is that he never
got to finish high school he really
regrets not finishing high school and
then by the time he comes back to earth
he's like
too old to be like all of his friends
have already graduated and moved on so
what if
teen dick writer is in the same ged
class
as unknown peter parker oh that would be
wild and very much like the cartoon
series like isn't um spider-man's on a
team with nova in the ultimate
spider-man cartoon series i'm not
mistaken i think so yeah so that would
be fitting i would just a lot of these
kids would be like oh yeah it's just
like the cartoons i would personally be
into that but then my other thought is
that if they introduced him as an adult
dick writer
that um
they could do it in a way where he's
mentoring the next nova sam alexander
and could be a thing
where in the same way that like in
ant-man hank pym was like ushering in
the new ant-man and passing down the
torch we could see something where he's
already like the nova prime in the
aftermath of
whatever the xander thanos debacle uh
that horrible thing uh
in the aftermath of anything really but
yeah i think it would be really cool to
see him like training a younger
nova as a mentor
i think that'd be really yes
yes because in the comics of course sam
alexander is like the young nova that
you know is on the champions team
alongside miles morales um you know miss
marvel um young girl vision like all of
them um and he's just a really great
character and i would i i really wanted
the mcu to go in that direction of like
go introducing with sam alexander but
having richard ryder be this like you
know sort of just like writer i used to
be uh i mean ah dammit having a adult
dick writer just being like ah i used to
be a nova and it sucked
my planet got exploded i didn't finish
high school and i'm mad about it i just
want dick writer to follow his dreams at
the end of the day i want him to do what
he exactly needs for dick whatever's
good for dick is good good for me
whatever you got to do for dick you got
to do it are we still talking about the
show or yeah we're talking about jake
okay what we're talking about
[Laughter]
brandon is watching this like jessica i
told you to put that down and i'm like
please explain to people what that is
because people probably have no idea
what you're waving around it's a 90s
early 2000s toy that you can put your
finger in
or any other phallic objects you go and
then you can shimmy it the 11th finger
the 11th finger yes and it's very
slippery and it might fall into your
drink and all over your keyboard right
before shooting like mine uh but i was
gonna say i was originally gonna say in
the comics i remember there was a part
where uh he's he's wandering dick ryder
is wandering now with drax and drax is
like dude why do you suck so hard and
dick writer is like because i have this
freaking world mind in my helmet telling
me what to do all the time and then i
have you badgering me and he gives him
the helmet and he's like oh i see your
problems now so i think that's a good if
we went with whitney's idea a great
thing of him being like that battle of
having this second thing in your head
constantly nagging you about what's
right what's wrong and how it's very
brilliant it's a million years old with
every human being or every xandarian on
like in its brain just being like i've
had enough and like throwing it down for
a second like making him as human as
possible is possible
i really do love that idea too because
like we're seeing that progressively
more in marvel movies because we saw
like you know that whole someone talking
to your head in venom it seems like
we're getting that in the upcoming moon
night so like yeah i really want that
element of the world mind directly
talking to um either richard or sam
alexander i really i really love that
moment in the comics as well um i
believe it's in the annihilation series
when um
is that when it happened with uh when
richard was talking to you yeah i think
so let me look at i can look it up just
to double check i read this ages ago
when dick was talking to drax minus one
you have me typing in dick writer on my
google just uh just a fact check and i
know it's gonna be bad whitney is the
official dick police for the next 30
minutes i am i'm looking for dick
writers on google.com yeah put a private
browser if you're gonna look that up i
believe that like the whole event of the
nova core and the nova force um being
destroyed in the comics was the
annihilation if i'm not mistaken either
that or the the phalanx um alliance
conquest that came afterwards um but
yeah it's i really
would it would be dope for a nova to be
introduced with the annihilation wave
because that is the the biggest marvel
event that actually triggered the birth
of our current version of the guardians
of the galaxy um from that first
annihilation event in like 20
2008 2009 i don't know it was a long
time ago um but yeah if it wasn't wasn't
for that we wouldn't have peter quill
and
in rock and raccoon on the same team um
but yeah but like just before i move on
what do you guys think is left of the
nova corps right now i i think
everyone's dead
i really hope that john c riley and his
family survived though
i think that's the important person that
has to die out of everyone else glencoe
is also very important to die but i feel
like going back and seeing that origin
story and seeing some john c reilly but
then after like everything happens
richard wait
dick writer wakes up and he sees like a
dead john c riley under rabbit rubble
rubbish rubbish or whatever so i
there has to be some there can't be
everyone's gone but i think the ones
that we've seen are definitely dead
yeah i totally agree i think that i
think that they you know whether it's in
the first ep you know the raise the
stakes kind of like heimdall getting uh
getting stabbed by thanos in the
beginning of infinity war if we if you
introduce or show characters we've
already been introduced to and then
having them bite the dust that would
really raise the stakes i think for the
rest of the show
but that would suck because i would want
to see them in it more you know but uh
yeah i know
i was gonna say it could be john c
riley's villain origin story
his entire family dies and now he's like
i'm gonna be
i'm gonna go crazy yeah
what if he's the villain and he's like
yeah i should have been i should have
got the world mine
i should have been dick redder i am the
dick rider now i really want to see john
c riley has a marvel villain that would
be hilarious that would be so funny he
would be a good villain he would be a
good bill him and david tennant him and
david tennant can play villains really
well so i think those two could easily
be a villain but no these were all
fantastic theories of course i'm gonna
give three million rogue points to tom
four million to jess but five million to
whitney for her amazing idea of just
having you know sam alexander and just
richard i mean dick ryder team up and um
you know just have richard just be like
a mentor of sorts it'd be cool
it'd be really dope it'd be really fun
but before we continue because up next
we are going to talk about how many of
our exes we'll see in multiverse of
madness wink wink
oh x not your actual x no why did you
terrify did you scare me like that oh my
god they're coming to the movie theater
they're sitting next to you
no
but no up next we are going to talk
about how many of our exes we are going
to see in multiverse of madness but
first when you shop at new
rockstarsmerch.com you're directly
supporting the channel and all the shows
that we make here including rogue theory
and we're super appreciative of that
support like a lot it means so much to
us so keep an eye out this week for the
new moonlight inspired latest obsession
shirt the hawkeye latest obsession shirt
was a huge hit and we're expecting the
same for this one so grab one quick
before they sell out at
newrockstarsmerch.com and if you're
anything like me you're probably better
at eating fancy food than you are at
making it and sunbasket delivers the joy
of eating with bold flavors organic
produce and sustainable seafood and
meats their award-winning chefs are
constantly innovating with new recipes
and global tastes to keep it interesting
each week with dozens of options stop
suffering through sad lunches some
basket has exciting new grain burrito
and noodle bowls for every day of the
week try the accioto citrus pork black
rice bibimbap or sichuan glass noodles
all of those will taste a lot better
than my pronunciation i promise because
i really i can't i don't know what
bibimbap is rachioto just eat eat and
love in minutes and you can put dinner
on autopilot with easy to prep meal kits
that impress for dateline or win over
picky eaters in your family so whether
you eat vegetarian paleo gluten-free or
low-carb high-protein some basket has
something to check every box set up
weekly delivery and skip a week when you
need to it's simple easy and you'll love
it and right now sunbasket is offering
90 off and a free gift when you order so
just go to sunbasket.com
rogue and enter promo code rogue at
checkout that's sunbasket.com rogue and
enter rogue at checkout and we thank
sunbasket for sponsoring this video now
we are all excited to see patrick
stewart return as professor x in the
upcoming multiverse of madness but is
that the only version of the omega level
mutant that we are going to see which
leads us to our second topic for today
will we actually see a young professor x
in multiverse of madness because james
mack have always said he would not be
appearing in the dr strange sequel
during an instagram live broadcast this
week and given that his version of
professor charles xavier is the same
character as patrick stewart it would
make sense that they wouldn't both
appear in the film in sort of a no way
home type scenario but
is james mcavoy actually telling the
truth could both xaviers appear in this
movie what do you guys think they always
lie like that uh uh it can't forget i
can't remember the actor's name but that
plays kang the conqueror he was like
what
no way shows the hell up andrew garfield
worst at hiding it shows up like they
always say that [ __ ]
they have to these days because i feel
like we're just like oh well no they
have to yeah they can't just outwardly
be like yes i would be in it oh what do
you ask
but that would be the plot twist just
reverse psychology hasn't been like i
actually am gonna be in it and then
don't show up
yeah
i i think it's like i pranked you i feel
like no he shouldn't be in it we have
one uh but if they did want him to
appear they can when they have the
illuminati meeting he's there right
older professor x and then uh patrick
obviously patrick stewart patrick
stewart patrick stewart professor x will
be there and then if they are jumping
through different universes and
different like time lines they could see
a younger one briefly like how they did
in um
the other x-men where they see like uh
wolverine and wolverine's like [ __ ] off
and they just like go back to their like
normal [ __ ] like okay my bad they could
easily be like a scene like that with
james mcavoy and i feel like james
mcavoy would show up to like play along
but also i could see them like
that's the thing
i prefer i would prefer that i would
love that i would love to see those two
show up in there because you can throw
you can throw anything at the wall in
this and so why not you have the money
disney just do it
but i could see the writers being like
this is too much
this is too much
there's already enough in this movie
this is my marge impression from the
simpsons
that's too much homie
homie this is too much homie no more
oh my god that's actually like a really
good margin
those are all valid ideas because like
you know we don't technically need him
to appear even though james mcavoy made
it up amazing professor x in his movies
um we don't necessarily need him because
we do have
this of the og in the film already so
like it doesn't necessarily have to
happen but it could still happen i don't
know what do you guys think i think i
think it should and here's the hell why
hmm because
we got a beautiful beautiful glimpse of
all of the x-men days of future past
there were so many bell-bottoms there
were so many bell-sleeve shirts
floral patterns vests with the little
leather fringe on it sunglasses you know
the drill so i want them to travel to
that multiverse of the x-men so that we
only get cool retro 60s james mcavoy
that's who i want to see yeah
i'd be hilarious without the panel and
you see you see project stored in like a
hover chair and then you see this other
dude with long hair just leaning back
walking around and you're like who the
hell is this guy he's like i'm xavier 2.
but i also took a serum so i can't use
my my power but i'm here dude and i'm
walking around yeah that would be
hilarious i just want a uh the the whole
cast of days of future pass just to be
in a that 70s situation where they're
all in the basement and they're just
smoking
and they go from person to person yeah
the cameras just panic from xavier to
magneto oh my god oh my god you just
made my new dream that every cast member
and had him go on once it'd still just
be like a 30 minute or one hour a scene
because he got to go through each
character that's ever been in these
movies
yeah i really do like the idea of like
going to some point in the past that
we've seen um in you know days of future
past especially that being like the best
my favorite x-men movie in my opinion um
and just like plucking out james mcavoy
and being like oh yeah you're doing this
adventure no you're not not yet anyway
and like it really does make sense for
them to do something like that
considering that like what if like this
professor x that we see in the trailer
what if he dies and the illuminati
doesn't have this super powerful
cerebral
abusing man so they're just like all
right he was old anyway so like let's go
to the younger version like he'll last
for a longer time what you got tom um
yeah i think they could easily do it uh
because
as we've established in the fox x-men
movies if anybody has multiverses it's
them because there's so many continuity
errors and
inconsistencies and like double
characters like double saber tooths and
double phoenixes even so uh i think they
could easily and they could easily have
um both be on there um kind of like what
woody was saying but just from different
timelines um because because it's in the
movies they've already established in
days of future past when you change
something it creates a new timeline so
who's to say that the mcavoy xavier is
from a different kind of path and
timeline versus the patrick stewart one
they could easily they could easily do
that and i think that maybe just for fun
they could even
um have them show up there
thanks to some like other mutants that
have connections to other dimensions
like um
nightcrawler can teleport and he goes
through this uh like brimstone kind of
dimension and um there's cloak from
cloak and dagger
uh there's right yeah blink is more of
like teleporting but uh she could maybe
do magic colossus sister can travel
through dimensions so maybe someone can
bring them to and fro as needed
so maybe like how kitty's powers were
augmented to send your mind through time
in days of future days of future past
maybe there's uh one of the other og
mutants who can now come and come and go
from the multiverse for these meetings
you know as xavier needs no like i
really like that idea because in the
comics we do have the exiles team and
like they are this huge multiverse x-men
team that they just travel across the
multiverse and do
lots of fun shenanigans so i would love
if the exiles were introduced in this
movie in that way because it'd be just
dope just uh just to have them like i
don't know interact with the timeline
and just mess things up i just thought
of something about based off what
whitney said is like maybe that uh or
maybe was i don't know if it was umt
what saying that the xavier died and
this is just another one that they
brought in like the patrick sewer one
they could maybe even start explaining
some of the x-men plot holes so when
xavier gets exploded by feet by jean
grey phoenix in last stand maybe he
didn't get exploded maybe he got sent
here that sent to this to this like
illuminati tribunal because then they
never explained it ever again all of a
sudden he rolls up again in that one
scene at the end of what was it the
wolverine and he's back in a wheelchair
and it's like wait but if you were
trying to imply at the end of x-men
three that he was getting a new body why
would he still need a wheelchair it was
just just a hot mess so maybe we could
they could use a multiverse of madness
to explain some of these plot holes and
explain where xavier went yeah i really
do like that idea and then like i really
do think that kevin feige will probably
want to prioritize something like this
because like we for for the years like
the whole x-men timeline has been so
confusing and like there's so many like
logic holes and like just so many
different things that like i feel like
kevin feige because of his early work on
the x-men series and earlier on in his
career he'd want to like fill in those
gaps either through multiverse or
madness or via loki a loki season 2
where like we have loki go through the
x-men timeline and just be like all
right this is why things are broken it's
because loki uh was just messing things
up and that's how they can introduce
mojo yeah yeah and then mojo comes in
no um i really do like that idea a lot
um it's really fun you guys are so smart
because i'm so lucky that i'll be
talking to all three of you guys love
you guys i love you guys y'all are the
best and the smartest and the sweetest
and the cutest you guys are the real
dick writers you guys are the real dick
riders come find me on the corner of
sunset
sunset and fern where i'm standing on
the corner with a bunch of these in a
trench coat
[Laughter]
oh my god but this leads us to our rogue
question are you guys ready for the
rogue question oh yeah yeah did you guys
know that there was a scrapped tim
burton superman film from the 90s called
superman lives that would have seen
nicholas cage as the man of steel do you
guys know that because yeah i don't want
to see that i don't i know that he's a
huge fan because he named his son after
superman he's a huge fan and then i
don't know if you guys have seen the uh
the like the set photos from
his like the costume that he was gonna
have yeah yeah yeah like the coffee yeah
costume test not set photos that's what
i meant to say yes he did what did he
play superman like the voice of superman
something recently was it the lego
batman movie or something no yeah and
the teen titans yeah i was like wasn't
he in the same times movie teen titan go
to the movies yeah the tee times go is
such a hilariously written show
is my favorite and it's so freaking it's
a separate thing it's a separate thing
it's a separate thing people it's a
separate thing and you can learn both of
them you can love both of them
god but anyways when asked in gq this
week why it still couldn't be made today
nicholas cage said there's still a
chance so
now there's still a chance pitch me your
rogue is superman story starring
nicholas cage as superman well the uh
you know what i i don't remember the
most i'm sorry go ahead jess go ahead
just no but if you steal my idea tom i'm
gonna be guaranteeing you i'm not gonna
steal it i'm gonna see you okay okay go
go go me okay okay just because this is
so dumb um
i remember speaking of the uh costume
tests uh that whitney was talking about
i remember him having his really long
hair and i can't help but remember his
character from conair and i was like
what if you did a superman
a superman movie but it was just a
remake of conair but it was cl him as
clark kent he's like don't touch the
bunny and and him now fighting like uh
criminals on a plane
and uh psychos and sickos and with all
the michael bay shots you can bring have
everybody come back but just change
change his name to clark kent and have
him be doing all the same things and he
could be like superman you're being
court-martialed because you accidentally
killed somebody you know with your heat
vision which is how come he ended up on
the plane with all of these people you
know maybe he accidentally as clark
can't like broke broke the guy's wrist
or killed the guy or whatever it was
uh but yeah they need to i think they
could do a con air but a soup like a
like a cal air that was out of cow
it seems like you already got the pilot
written my dude like we already got this
going uh yeah actually i got i'm gonna
go start writing this before i forget
hang on i'll be back
just as
grungy so i think that
uh today's nicholas cage plays a really
good grungy if you saw pig like i want
that dark of what nicolas cage is doing
now so
i want like 2006 watchmen dark i want
the superman to have the passes your man
already has because we also know that
superman had just like a mishap of like
is he bad or is he good like which one
is he and i want this version of
superman to have accidentally killed
like either a bunch of people and at the
end of the day they're like well he's
superman maybe we can just stop him from
being a superhero fast forward and this
is old man superman that's like an
alcoholic that doesn't do anything
everyone in the town knows who he is and
hates him because they're like oh that's
superman the guy that killed a bunch of
people i wanted dark and gritty and then
he has to fit like he someone comes in
and is like you need to save the day
again and he's like i can't
like they won't let me the law doesn't
want me so we're getting like anti-law
like we're getting batman the batman but
we're getting old man nicholas cage as
superman that has already been
ostracized by the town that that's what
i want i want a sad superman story this
superman is just like is like imagine
like jessica jones is that it's drinking
a lot having sex in bars like oh it is
hancock it is hancock it is a
nicholas cage's hancock 100
thank you mt one could be in the suit
being like drinking at the bar like a
christopher reeves in superman four like
drunk superman just sitting at the bar i
said we need your help soups it's like a
busy yeah you know
nicholas cage sucker back yeah yeah i
would love to see the type of story for
nicholas cage because like like you said
with pig like he can play these type of
like really like dark characters and
like you know seeing a superman who just
like has to slowly regain his hope for
humanity and his love for humanity it'd
be really fun and i think nicholas cage
would knock that out of the park it's a
really fun idea i like that just you're
smart you're smart
but bring us home whitney what you got
okay so hear me out this is a weird one
but uh have you guys ever seen
the horror comedy willie's wonderland of
course
and jess i don't need to say more to you
you know what i mean he's just quiet
he just drunk and like comes into chuck
e cheese and beats the [ __ ] out of the
thing
as long as he has his beer he's fine you
know what i don't know much about this
movie but this sounds a lot like the
superman villain toy man
um
[Music]
well i love all of these answers but i'm
gonna have to give the rogue points i'm
gonna give 10 million rogue points to
jessica clemens for her amazing pitch
for an old man in hancock
i love seeing old man versions of
superhero characters so give me that all
day long so i'm going to say jess is the
winner for this one because she just got
10 million bajillion actually points and
she has she's the winner for having the
uh the pre-pubescent boys dream
no i don't want to play with it no i
don't want it anymore
[Laughter]
but that is it for this episode of rogue
theory i want to thank our guests tom
michelson whitney van laningham and
jessica clements for joining me this
episode support our channel by checking
out all of our awesome merch over at
newrockstarsmerch.com and if you've got
some rogue theories of your own you can
share them over on our discord if you
are over 18. so just click the link in
the new rockstars discord server to in
the description below and to join the
conversation you can follow me at
mastertainment on twitter to see me
tweet some weird [ __ ] follow the new
rockstars wherever we are on social
media and be sure to subscribe to our
channel here on youtube thank you guys
so much for watching we love you so so
much we'll see you guys next time
goodbye
[Music]
you